YURI GRINSHTEYN: It's more
important than ever for teams
to take ownership of the
reliability of their services.
This is especially true in
distributed environments,
like an e-commerce
website that depends
on services like
inventory, shopping
cart, and notifications.
Today, we'll look at how to
use data from a service mesh
to understand traffic,
error rates, and latencies
in microservice applications
with Stackdriver.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Developers use microservices
to architect for portability,
scale, and decoupling.
This presents some challenges
with operations and management.
You have to manage all
of the various services
and understand the
interactions between them.
This is where a
service mesh comes in.
Let's take a look at how a
service mesh and Stackdriver
can work together to
help us understand
what's going on in a
distributed application.
To start, we need services.
We'll use this application.
It's a web store that
sells really cool products.
It also happens to be composed
of a number of microservices
written in a variety
of languages.
You can take a look
at it for yourself
in this GitHub repository.
In a complex
environment like this,
how can we go about
measuring reliability?
This is where a service
mesh is going to help us.
But first, what
is a service mesh?
According to the Istio
open source project,
a service mesh is
used to describe
the network of
microservices that
make up distributed applications
and the interactions
between them.
The real value of a
service mesh like Istio
is that it enhances the
security, reliability,
and observability
of services, which
are not necessarily easy to
do in Kubernetes without it.
What does that mean for us?
Well, let's take a
look at what happens
when we have our microservices
application managed
by a service mesh.
First, let's create
a GKE cluster
with Istio already
installed on it.
Here's the command we'll
use to create the cluster
and enable Istio.
This will automatically set
up the Stackdriver adapter
to send metrics, logs,
and traces to Stackdriver.
Now that the cluster's
up and running,
let's deploy our
microservices application.
Here are all the
services that it creates.
These services are instrumented
with the proxy sidecar.
The proxies send
telemetry information
to a component called Mixer,
which in turn sends it
to Stackdriver.
Let's go there and see what
new information is available.
We'll start in the
metrics explorer.
If we search for
Istio, we'll see
all of the new metrics that
are created by Istio for all
of the services in the mesh.
The first thing we want
to do is to configure
alerting using these metrics
so that we can find out
if any of our services have
issues with performance
or availability.
First, let's create an alerting
policy for front-end latency.
We'll use the server
response latency metric
filtered by destination service
name for just our front end,
and further filter
by response code
to just measure latency
for successful requests.
Now let's create
another alerting policy
for our front end availability.
This time, we'll use the
server request count metric.
We'll also filter by destination
service name for the front end,
and then further filter
it to only count responses
that do not return a success.
And there we go.
Now we're using information
from the service mesh
to let us know when
our front end service
experience is in degradation in
either latency or availability.
But what happens when we do get
an alert that there's an issue
and our service is degraded?
If the problem has
to do with latency,
we'd want to start by
looking at tracing.
Well, the good news is that
the Stackdriver adapter
in the service mesh is not
just sending metric data,
it's also exporting traces.
We don't need to do anything
to instrument our code.
The service mesh
trace has serviced
the service calls for us and
sends the data to Stackdriver.
On the other hand,
if the problem
has to do with
availability or errors,
we would want to have
easy access to debugging
information, like logs.
The service mesh is also
exporting logs to Stackdriver.
We can look at Kubernetes
container logs for the proxy,
for example, to see a
record of all requests.
If there are any issues
we need to debug,
this can be a great
source of information.
So thanks to the data being
exported by the service mesh
to Stackdriver, we've
configured alerting and service
availability and performance,
looked at latency with traces,
and dug into logs.
Come back next
time, when we look
at improving observability even
further with custom metrics.
That's it for this episode.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]